let's get to chris hemsworth who's
giving our cassie delora the naked truth
on his new nude scene
yes we are at the world's premiere for
chris's thor love and thunder or should
i say love thunder and booty
and flick
oh love thunder and booty
we're gonna re-title the film now flick
too hard dammit in the film
is the booty blurred like the trailer
you get full booty in the movie you can
hear it right here from me
full booty
full crisp booty in high definition go
see it on imax it's even bigger
did you have to do extra squats or
anything like that there's a lot of work
yeah i mean it was kind of
10 11 years in the making that shot
each film we've taken off another item
of clothing and now we just kind of took
it all off
good to know chris has a sense of humor
about these things but who's really the
funniest hemsworth brother we talked to
tessa thompson earlier this week and she
said that luke was the funniest
hemsworth brother
i agree i'd agree you still stand by
that statement maybe it's like whichever
hemsworth i happen to be
at the premiere of something with i
should say is the funniest hemsworth so
tonight it's chris and liam when you and
i finally do something together it'll be
you am i uh sensing feelings
tessa thompson's back as valkyrie for
thor love and thunder hitting theaters
july 8th also reuniting with chris his
former flame played by natalie portman
would you say in this film
his biggest weakness is jane foster i
don't know if he has any weaknesses
chris is pretty much the all-around
perfect perfect
superhero rounding out the cast as the
creepiest villain in the marvel universe
christian bale everyone looked and went
a little too much is it like have we
gone a little too scary a little too
creepy well that's those are scenes that
were cut that you don't see in the film
[Music]